andrew hi piani oh my gosh
um are you the reason i couldn't find
strawberries easily
at my store you know what's so
funny is just a couple days ago because
my kids
love strawberries so much and i'm always
trying to
give them fruits and vegetables that
they do
or don't want strawberries was something
i was just
figuring out what the nutritional
benefits are because that's their
favorite fruit
so this is so apropos that we're doing
this
wait what makes strawberries nutritional
do you know they have vitamin c
uh they have fiber antioxidants
folate potassium and it's fat free
cholesterol free and low in calories and
it's probably my favorite flavor whether
it's a lip balm
a fruit a scented something like a
flavored something
strawberry is my go-to yeah
yeah so what we're making today drew for
my new cookbook
is a breakfast poke bowl and this is
completely vegan
so pokey bowl traditionally has like raw
fish in it but this is a sweet
vegan version of this and the
strawberries
that's sort of the the protein or the
fish in there and then the rice we're
using this beautiful
jasmine rice which i love is so fragrant
and it's so delicious and we've cooked
it in almond milk
to give it a lot of richness but what i
would want to tell everyone at home is
don't get the pre-cooked jasmine rice i
know it's a time saver really to cook
this on your own
it's more economical and it only takes
about 15 minutes max to cook your own
rice
yeah yeah i i hear you on that one
okay so what we're going to start with
first is in a bowl right here i have
some almond milk about half a cup of
almond milk and we're going to add a
little bit of sweetener
which is maple syrup so about two
tablespoons two to three tablespoons
maple syrup syrup is so hot right now
danny it really is
remember it was like stevia or this
sweetener or agave
maple syrup is having its moment it's
having a huge moment
and then the way that we make this a uh
a matcha
breakfast pokeball is that we need
matcha which is ground
tea leaves yes there's this beautiful
vibrant green color and we're going to
add this
to our bowl people go crazy
for matcha also that was so hot for a
while but it never
went away people are like freaks with
matcha
they have their whisk their wooden whisk
and their morning rituals or they
go buy it you know in their local coffee
tea place
like matcha is where it's at people
go crazy for matcha and what we do once
you mix that together you want to
you want to toss this with your rice
and we're going to mix it all together
just like this you get this beautiful
fragrant jasmine almond milk rice oh
this is
gorgeous yeah it's a little bitter you
know from the matcha but then you get
that beautiful sweetness from the almond
milk and
the maple syrup and so the combination
really makes it nice but
what really brightens it is what we do
to the strawberries
and so what i've done here with the
strawberries is that you want to just
you know slice the strawberries into
little rounds like this
and one little trick that we'd love to
do and you don't want to skip this step
is that i've grated ginger okay
and you've grated it on a box grater and
then you can either put it in a
cheesecloth like that or what i do is
i put it right in my hands juice it and
then you squeeze it
you see that see how much juice is
coming out i do
right here and i love a good cheesecloth
moment danny i'll wear
cheesecloth i'll cook with cheesecloth
i'm a hippie and i loves me some
cheesecloth
but the ginger just gives it it that's a
natural tenderizer for the strawberries
it adds another dimension and flavor
profile
and within seconds it transforms
boring not so great strawberries into
the best
tasting strawberries ever i have to say
when i bit
into that strawberry and i had forgotten
about the ginger detail
i got like a classic zing moment i was
like
oh my gosh like oh
i love ginger and the one thing we
forgot if you have it
it's kind of optional black sesame seeds
if you want to sprinkle them on top i
ran out of black sesame seeds in my own
house so i'm using hemp hearts
whatever you want to add on top to give
it a little crunch and that's it
we have we have breakfast right here and
i love how
when you say a vegan pokeball
that the strawberries look like the tuna
i know now we get to eat right
i'm drooling i don't want to go sean
[Laughter]
holy cow danny
oh my god
the rice is like nothing i've ever
tasted
thank you so much but it's also so good
for you because you've got
all the nutrition of the strawberries
that you beautifully pointed out
the antioxidants of the green matcha
you've got
the protein and the fiber from the rice
so this has been one of my favorites
economical you know this is a doable
dish with time
and economy and i have to say it's so
colorful and beautiful
and you always know how to make healthy
fun so thank you gianni this is a game
changer
and you know how to make fun fun
[Laughter]
i'm a good time gal
[Music]
you